I think each one it falls into their own
sort of personality of the country and,
and,
and uh,
its own DNA.
You know,
New York is very fast moving.
It's very crisp.
It's to the point it's all about
business.
I'm New York fashion tends to be like
that.
It tends to be no nonsense.
The venues are sensible.
It's an,
an organized,
orderly way.
Um,
America's known for sports where that is
separate pieces that are put together.
That's what the American,
I think great contribution to fashion
has been.
Um,
that's where America continues to do and
do well.
The English and London fashion week,
which is currently going on now are
known for Eccentricity,
outlandishness theatrics.
You know,
the land of Shakespeare that gone crazy
and wild.
They do it in extraordinary venues.
Inconveniently late at night,
um,
with great three atrik theatrical and
drama.
Um,
that's the English point of view.
Uh,
the Italians are,
get,
are known for craftsmanship.
It's the fabrics.
It's the ability to make beautiful
clothing.
That's what the Italians have always
known how to do.
Great leather goods,
great,
great fabrics,
great seems true.
Seeming and tailoring,
you know,
beautiful suits.
That's what Italians too,
and that's what they do best as well.
Um,
and then you get to Paris and that's
just,
you know,
the magic city of all in my mind,
that's where the couture exists.
Those one of a kind dresses that the
French put out twice a year,
um,
which is really a more of what's factory
for extraordinary design in fashion that
is only really in,
in Paris and supported by the French
and,
and even by the French government and
the French have in there.
I mean,
it's in the water,
it's in the wine,
it's in the baguette.
Uh,
uh,
it's in their DNA.
A sense of style,
a sense of that being important.
I mean,
French fashion is a port of French
culture in the way,
uh,
you know,
the American flag is a symbol of him
being an American.
Um,
it's just,
it's just a part of who they are.
I think they do it better than anybody
else.
And I think their level of understanding
of it is,
is more sophisticated.
Even if the designer,
Stephanopoulos and Italian Alber bows
isn't,
uh,
isn't Israeli,
but they,
they are both designing for houses in
power as they are in that culture there
in that world.
Bark Jacobs does Louie Vito.
Um,
it just,
you know,
you get absorbed into that French ethos,
that femininity,
uh,
the understanding of quality and
craftsmanship,
the work that are still there that do
the beautiful embroidery.
Mr lasage doesn't happen anywhere else
on the planet.
And I think along with the French
government supporting French fashion,
um,
it's just a city that really does
[inaudible] and they have I think
basically the best clothes on the
planet.
Yeah,
they care about it.
Um,
you know,
the French woman traditionally goes and
buys a couple of pieces each season
jacket,
maybe coat new pair of boots,
a skirt,
and she wears that for the six months.
And she really,
those few things because then with her
old pieces and then get something new in
spring,
American women don't tend to buy that
way.
They tend to buy more things.
They don't tend to buy investment
pieces.
Uh,
I think American women would tend to
make more mistakes and what they buy.
Um,
so there there's a different philosophy.
I think it's in the culture as well.
I think French women are brought up to
care more about that in a way that seems
to be more part of what's important.
And that might have to do with something
deeper sociological,
psychological relationship that they
have with men in their society.
The,
where the female relationship is,
how men view women and sexuality.
And it's a slightly more Latin point of
view.
And that in my mind,
might indicate why the women are a
little more interested in their style
and their,
okay.